[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous et
bienvenue c'est Science Publique 90
minutes pour donner du sens à
l'actualité grâce à nos experts on est
ensemble tous les jours du lundi au
jeudi à 18h et 22h sur Public Sénat et
c'est parti pour 90 minutes d'actualité
voici le sommaire de ce 7 septembre la
guerre en Ukraine d'abord marquée par de
nouvelles scènes d'horreur après le
bombardement russe d'un marché dans
l'est du pays des dizaines de civils
tués ou blessés ravivant la compassion
pour un peuple ukrainien qui résiste
depuis plus de 18 mois
dieu merci nous sommes en vie mais les
vendeuses là-bas elles sont toutes
mortes en un instant une fille et un
enfant un petit enfant mort
pourquoi la contre-offensive ukrainienne
piétine les munitions à uranium appauvri
promis par promise par les États-Unis
peuvent-elles changer la donne pourquoi
sont-elles controversées on répond à
toutes ces questions dans une minute et
dans notre second débat c'est un zoom
sur les élections sénatoriales que je
vous propose le 24 septembre les sièges
de
170 sénatrices et sénateurs seront
renouvelés ça concerne 42 départements
français les enjeux sont nombreux d'une
éventuelle arriver d'élus du
rassemblement national à la cinquième
élection de Gérard Larcher à la tête de
la Haute Assemblée en passant par une
possible Bérézina pour la majorité
présidentielle on analyse ces enjeux
dans 45 minutes mais d'abord donc cette
frappe russe sur un marché de la région
de deniersk Audrey Vittaz
une frappe russe à l'heure du marché
nous sommes à l'est de l'Ukraine à 20 km
du front l'attaque va tuer 17 personnes
et ont blessé une trentaine la vidéo a
été relayée par volodimeerselens qui
lui-même sur son compte telegram les
terroristes russes ont attaqué un marché
ordinaire
lithumanité la plus totale le mal russe
doit être vaincu dès que possible
qui vient de nommer un nouveau ministre
de la Défense et promet de récupérer
chaque centimètre du territoire
ukrainien mais la contre-offensive prend
du temps plus que prévu concède le
secrétaire général de l'OTAN même s'il y
a eu deux percées récentes dans le flanc
russe à l'esté au sud les
Ukrainiens gagnent progressivement du
terrain et cela montre l'importance du
soutien que nous leur apportons
hier lors d'une visite surprise en
Ukraine les États-Unis ont annoncé de
nouvelles livraisons d'armes c'est un
message que les États-Unis envoient
aujourd'hui avec un nouveau programme
d'aide en matière de sécurité qui
comprend davantage de munitions pour
l'artillerie ainsi que des systèmes de
défense aériennes qui aideront l'Ukraine
à protéger sa population contre les
attaques comme celle qui vient d'avoir
lieu
dans cette nouvelle livraison et c'est
une première les États-Unis fourniront à
l'Ukraine des munitions à uranium
appauvri plus efficace contre les chats
voilà pour analyser les toutes dernières
infos en provenance d'Ukraine
j'accueille le général Christophe Gomart
bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue ancien chef du
renseignement militaire à vos côtés
Mariana pierre et Vénissieux que bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi journaliste
franco-ukrainienne ou collaboré à
hebdomadaire
Ukraine skittisden et le média
deskrussie Jérôme klecht bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue à vous vous êtes enseignants
en prospective et stratégie à Sciences
Po Paris et auteur de ce livre la
prospective stratégique une nouvelle
approche pour améliorer la prise de
décision qui est publiée aux éditions
brochez j'accueille également Tam
traduis dans dans le rôle de
l'éditorialiste politique bienvenue tram
bonsoir nous avoir sur ce plateau on va
commencer il y a beaucoup de thèmes à
aborder on parlera évidemment des des
annonces de livraison de ces armes à
uranium appauvri un peu plus tard dans
le débat si vous voulez bien il venait
pas tout de suite parce que je voudrais
d'abord qu'on parle de cette frappe
russe sur un marché général golard ça
s'appelle comment dans le il y a un
droit de la guerre ça s'appelle comment
ce qui s'est passé c'est pas la première
fois mais ça ça c'est pas la première
fois sans doute malheureusement pas la
dernière en tous les cas tant que cette
gaine sera pas terminée ça arrive
malheureusement toutes les guerres alors
est-ce que c'est intentionnel est-ce que
c'est une erreur de tir ça
les Russes utilisent pas tellement de
munitions très précises donc il est
possible que ce soit une erreur de tir
comme ça peut arriver est-ce que cette
intentionnel vous savez pendant la
Première Guerre mondiale les Allemands
utilisaient des bombardés d'ailleurs
Paris directement donc en fait l'idée
derrière pour tout ennemi c'est d'aller
bombarder les aspects logistiques et
donc de taper sur les arrières de
l'adversaire pour tenter le faire
fléchir et tenter de casser le moral de
faire en sorte qu'il de lèvent les
pouces pour demander l'arrêt des combats
est-ce que c'est dans ce cadre là c'est
difficile de le dire sincèrement en tous
les cas c'est atroce c'est terrible pour
cette pauvre population ukrainienne qui
est sous les obus et pour les familles
des morts et en particulier enfin ceux
qui ont été tués comme sur le marché en
particulier c'était des marchands de
visiblement donc ça c'est terrible alors
comment on appelle ça c'est je sais pas
moi de définir j'allais dire il y a des
instances juridiques qui sont mieux de
le faire comment ça s'est passé
exactement voilà je c'est difficile de
se prononcer directement mais je vous
pose cette question parce qu'on est on
aimait nous collectivement je pense à
nous aussi observateurs parfois il y a
une espèce de banalisation de de parce
que il y a déjà eu d'autres frappes bien
sûr bien sûr ça reste là
faut pas qu'on banalise qu'il s'est
passé sur ce marché Mariana périmé siouk
comment ça se passe dans votre pays
quand un événement comme ça se passe
restons sur ce premier thème ça renforce
l'esprit de résistance il y a une fois
une forme de lassitude de peur qui
regagne les régions où ça s'est passé
comment ça se passe
[Musique]
du fait que ça continue à se reproduire
à ce que les forces armées russes
continuent à cibler sans cesse les
civils et là où il a les marchés il est
supermarchés les expositions
les concerts enfin parfois dans la rue
là ça montre quand même qu'il y a une
volonté des terroriser la population et
comme toujours dans ce cas-là cela ne
marche pas ça produit beaucoup de
douleurs ça produit beaucoup de colère
mais ça ne marche pas
sans parler de cette frappe qui est
peut-être trop récente mais sur d'autres
parce que c'est ce que je disais il y en
a eu beaucoup d'autres est-ce qu'on sait
est-ce qu'on sait si c'est une stratégie
si c'est des erreurs de tir est-ce qu'on
peut catégoriser en quelque sorte ses
frappes sur des qui visent des enfin
volontairement volontairement je ne sais
pas qui vise des civils bah j'allais
dire oui malheureusement on peut la
catégoriser et celle-ci comme les autres
parce que ça relève finalement d'une
stratégie d'attrition qui a commencé
depuis à peu près novembre dernier côté
russe il faut voir dans quel cadre en
fait dans quel contexte intervient cette
frappe là ça fait maintenant trois mois
que la contre-offensive est lancée ça
fait à peu près trois mois qu'au niveau
du front Centrest c'est à dire au sud de
darknout et on connaît l'aspect tactique
important et symbolique de barkout ça
fait trois mois que il y a d'autres
combats des échanges de tir d'artillerie
de drones et que finalement il n'y a pas
d'évolution majeur or on voit que sur le
front sud-est là il y a une tentative de
percée on y reviendra ou les forces
ukrainiennes commencent à questionner la
première ligne de défense sur donc il y
a un impératif pour la Russie de frapper
fort à un endroit où il y a un statu quo
qui représente un enjeu tactique et
symbolique important et frappe et fort
il y a une stratégie civile théorisée
depuis très longtemps et j'y viens c'est
les cercles de Warden en général avec
les centres de commandement le plus
important si je puis dire des centres
névralgiques des infrastructures la
population et ensuite seulement les
forces armées c'est à dire que quand on
frappe la population selon cette théorie
qui existe depuis longtemps on frappe
plus fort que si on frappe la force
armées alors on va pas forcément
revendiquer puisqu'on a dans le cadre
d'une stratégie aussi et d'une guerre
d'informationnelle où il faut éviter
d'avoir le mauvais rôle mais on va pas
non plus laisser à penser que ça peut
être un accident ou alors ça fait
beaucoup d'accidents depuis novembre
2022 quand même voilà des innocents tués
sur un marché les images elles renforce
également la solidarité internationale
une réaction celle de la porte-parole de
Joe Biden à la Maison Blanche
aujourd'hui la Russie a lancé une
nouvelle vague de frappez aériennes
contre le peuple ukrainien tuant au
moins 16 personnes et en blessant des
dizaines d'autres ces attaques brutales
de la Russie soulignent la nécessité de
continuer à soutenir le peuple ukrainien
dans la défense de son territoire contre
une agression russe injustifiée et sans
précédent alors justement le la
nécessité de continuer à soutenir
l'Ukraine un regard sur l'aide des pays
occidentaux qui ne faiblit pas avec ces
informations de la Commission européenne
qui
évalue à 76 milliards d'euros d'aide
l'Union européenne depuis le début de la
guerre l'Ukraine et aux Ukrainiens c'est
il y a du soutien financier humanitaire
budget d'urgence soutien militaire à
l'Ukraine Gérald gomard est-ce qu'on
peut alors c'est pas c'est pas un
concours évidemment mais si on compare
l'Europe donne-t-elle autant plus que
les que les États-Unis qu'est-ce qu'on
en sait c'est ça qui est assez
intéressant je trouve ces de faire
l'additionner et les différents dons au
d'aide apporter aux Ukrainiens en
additionnant les pays européens parce
qu'en fait quand on regarde ce que donne
les Américains en fait ils donnent moins
en termes de volume financiers donc
c'est 70 ou 71 milliards en fait c'est
un peu moins donc en fait on peut pas
non plus j'allais dire s'auto flageller
en disant donne pas assez je dis on
donne est suffisant ça c'est une autre
question en tous les cas on donne
beaucoup alors certes la France donne
moins que la Grande-Bretagne et la
France donne elle apporte des éléments
d'ailleurs on ne sait même pas tous que
la France donner réellement c'est ça qui
est intéressant c'est d'additionner les
deux je trouve donc en fait si on
additionne les deux c'est quand même 140
milliards d'euros de d'aide à la fois
militaire c'est vrai que les Américains
doivent peut-être plus en termes d'aide
militaire oui parce que d'autres pays
européens il y a le soutien humanitaire
à ce bilan mais est-ce que cette
question qu'on est en train de se poser
elle va pas devenir au fur et à mesure
que cette guerre dure de plus en plus
importante parce que il y a les opinions
publiques de ces pays occidentaux
au-delà de ça pour moi il y a un vrai
une vraie question c'est la question des
munitions qui restent de mon point de
vue majeur c'est-à-dire que les pays de
l'OTAN ont donné ce qu'il pouvait et en
termes de capacité de production il me
semble que même s'ils ont augmenté cette
capacité elle reste insuffisante par
rapport aux besoins de des armées
ukrainiennes
en comparativement d'ailleurs les Russes
ont le même besoin c'est à dire qu'on
arrive à une espèce de famine des
munitions et c'est comme ça qu'on voit
les Russes qui ont encore et du Nord ou
qui vont effectivement frapper chez les
Iraniens pour leur demander
effectivement des des soutien en
munitions donc en fait la question va se
poser là c'est également donc de char
puisque un centre d'entrée ont été
détruit un nombre de canons puisqu'on
envoie sur l'image également détruit
donc c'est là où l'aide militaire va
jouer c'est à dire que il y a une
capacité de production est-ce que la
capacité de production occidentale en
terme de mission suffisante je pose la
question je n'ai pas la réponse je ne
suis pas certain que ça soit suffisent
rien à perdre le général vient de le
dire on sait pas se précisément quelles
armes sont sont livrées et c'est pas un
hasard évidemment c'est c'est
stratégique de pas donner la liste et de
et surtout pas dire quel armes et quand
on les livre c'est il faut le rappeler
quand même passionnant ce nom il faut
donner aussi l'adresse de livraison en
tant qu'à faire non non bien entendu
après vous voyez alors je suis heureuse
que générale s'est exprimée avant moi
donc vous voyez on ne cache rien mais
c'est vrai que c'est difficile de
tenir compte
au sens figural de ce qui a été livré
mais parce que ces gens d'information ne
sont pas publiques pour l'ensemble de
livraison mais c'est d'autant plus
difficile et également de de faire
l'appréciation est-ce que c'est
suffisant est-ce que ce n'est pas
suffisant dans la mesure où justement
c'est ces listes là parce que ça
fonctionne avec de liste de besoins si
vous voulez de la part de l'armée
ukrainienne de l'état major ukrainien
bien entendu ces listes ne sont pas
publiques également parce que si on
avait ces listes on aurait pu imaginer
les opérations ça tient ça parce que
dans les premiers mois de la guerre il y
avait vraiment ces consignes de de
silence de discrétion donnée aux soldats
craignaient au palais de guerre
informationnel ça tient ça il y a
toujours ce
cette volonté respectée de la part des
soldats sur le terrain ou des officiers
des officiers de d'en dire le moins
possible et il me semble que oui et par
ailleurs même je pense que nos collègues
qui seront de l'Ukraine elles peuvent
confirmer que bien entendu si elle se
rendent dans le don de base et s'ils se
parle avec les avec les militaires en
présence du matériel en question ils
peuvent en parler tout à fait librement
mais en ce qui concerne tout le reste de
l'Ukraine les circuits logistiques les
sites des productions les sites des
réparations vous n'entendrez jamais
parler de ce sujet là de la part de de
des simples civils ou même de militaires
qui se retrouvent dans les arrières j'ai
honte est-ce que le temps joue contre
l'ukrainement le facteur temps joue pour
la Russie que ce soit en termes de
capacité on parle de la capacité à durer
plus globalement dans cette guerre et
effectivement l'aide dont vous parliez
et le volume dont on parle et la façon
qualitativement dont on fournit sa
conditionne plus généralement cette
capacité à durer elle est conditionnée
par le la possibilité de régénérer les
ressources humaines tout simplement ça
c'est à l'avantage très clairement de la
Russie les capacités de renouveler
l'équipement on se souvient que au
lendemain de la contrée initiale à la
contre-offensive de celle de l'an
dernier
Vladimir Poutine disait 30 à 50% de
l'aide internationale et décimée
évidemment c'était de l'intoxication
aujourd'hui on peut simplement dire que
l'Ukraine engage ces brigades de
réserves la 36e brigade de réserve
semble-t-il sur robotan bon ça veut dire
qu'on commence à taper un peu dans les
réserves précisé humaine aussi humaines
et de la guerre et c'était des incarnés
à l'instant et aussi en matériel donc
maintenant il faut être capable aussi de
se régénérer voilà tout ça est à
l'avantage malgré tout de la Russie et
puis en effet puisque cette guerre est
quand même alimentée par l'aide
internationale on n'en serait pas là
aujourd'hui et c'est heureux s'il y
avait pas eu cette aide internationale
vous parliez des opinions publiques à
commencer par l'opinion publique
américaine bientôt des élections qui
sont déjà en fait entamées ça dure un an
aux États-Unis chacun le sait ça va plus
ça va prendre une tournure encore plus
forte lorsque les primaires seront
finies certainement d'ici début 2024 et
donc ça veut dire que si vous
additionnez le facteurs tant mais là
j'entends la météo c'est à dire que dans
deux mois les capacités progression au
sol sont largement
entravés par cette fameuse raspoutidza
et puis
la saison des pluies
sont beaucoup moins praticables d'un
point de vue tactique pour les forces
terrestres il est exclusivement
malheureusement
question que de force terrestres
quasiment pour ce qui est de la pour ce
qui est de l'Ukraine c'est pas le cas
pour la Russie on y reviendra je mets
les drones de côté et donc cette
capacité à avancer va être en travée et
la capacité à se régénérer sur le plan
des équipements va l'être parce que il y
aura une pression américaine pour sortir
de cette guerre donc le temps
effectivement joue contre l'Ukraine
alors on est toujours nous pressé de
faire des bilans ou d'avoir des des
leçons définitives mais ça fait trois
mois est-ce qu'on peut parler d'un échec
de cette contre-offensive
oui autant au sens où il y a pas eu de
percée
maintenant les ça a montré en même temps
que les Ukrainiens avaient une véritable
volonté d'avancer on le savait dans tous
les cas même si effectivement comme lire
votre partage en fait les Russes
avancent légèrement au nord et puis à
l'est en revanche jésus-chrenier avance
au sud
donc c'est on voit bien qu'il y a une
espèce de stabilisation du front et que
aucun des deux adversaires en fait
n'avantage sur l'autre la vraie la vraie
problématique c'est ce que disait j'ai
aucun à l'instant c'est à dire c'est la
capacité à durer la capacité à régénérer
ses forces et on voit bien que les
Ukrainiens pratiquement consomment un
bataillon c'est-à-dire environ 400 à 500
hommes pour conquérir une dizaine une
dizaine de kilomètres carrés c'est plus
facile de défendre vous avez déjà dit
sur ce plateau et donc c'est horrible ce
que je dis mais les rhumes les Russes
consomment
d'hommes dans dans
les termes sont insupportables mais
c'est c'est ce qui se passe parce que en
général on dit qu'à l'attaque il faut
trois attaquants pour face à un
défenseur pourquoi parce que défenseur
quand on défend on envoie en général
deux parce qu'on a eu le temps de se
préparer sur des positions prépa à
l'avance il y a des pièges devant elle a
bien vu le nombre de mines au mètre
carré c'est incroyable et dès que
éventuellement les Ukrainiens avancent
les Russes relancent par obus des mines
qui se dispersent sur champ de bataille
et donc en fait c'est un travail qui
doit être commencé en permanence donc en
fait c'est très compliqué pour les
Ukrainiens de percer on voit bien ce
qu'ils cherchent à faire du côté de
robotines justement c'est en fait il
cherche à atteindre la mère d'Azov qui
est une centaine de kilomètres plus plus
au sud sud-est de façon effectivement
tenter de couper cette partie détenue
par les Russes elle est encore ensuite
on parle de ces livraisons enfin
promises d'armes uranium appauvri est-ce
que ce mot d'échec il est employé
parfois dans les médias Ukrainiens alors
du tout alors non premièrement pas du
tout et il faut comprendre que
contrairement aux experts
occidentaux ont mis à occidentaux qui
ont imaginé ce scénario de soit ça passe
soit ça casse enfin l'offensif qui
change tout ce n'est ça n'a jamais été
les états d'esprit des enseignants par
ailleurs le ministre des Affaires
étrangères d'Ukraine métropoliba l'avait
dit aux médias
occidentaux au mois de mai 2023 que
arrêter de poser cette question il y
aura autant d'offensifs qui le faudra
pour libérer l'Ukraine seulement pour
pour continuer j'aimerais bien quand
même réagir et enfin corriger un tout
petit peu la formule de la guerre est
alimentée par l'aide
occidentale non ce n'est pas la guerre
qui est alimentée c'est la résistance
ukrainienne qui est alimentée par l'aide
internationale et c'est tant mieux
espérons que bientôt ça sera la victoire
parce que justement nous parlons du
temps du temps qui dure et ce n'est pas
vraiment ce n'est dans l'en-tête
personne sauf probablement de la Russie
qui elle souffre également du fait que
ce conflit dur mais c'est bien entendu
très éprouvant pour les Ukrainiens mais
c'est également difficile pour les
Alliés Ukrainiens
dans le discours des uns des autres
c'est que avec le voilà l'hiver qui va
arriver les conditions météo qui vont se
compliquer cette elle est partie pour
durer encore de longs mois et donc voilà
plus on est loin je comprends votre
réaction mais plus on est loin
finalement
de du front du quotidien vécu par les
Ukrainiens plus cette attente peut-être
compliqué à accepter on parlait des
opinions internationales c'est un
élément et je suis convaincu que le
président ukrainien a intégré à son
équation qu'il faut prendre en compte
alors c'est même là c'est même pour ça
qu'il faut rappeler que la guerre elle
n'est toujours pas depuis un an et demi
la guerre dure depuis 9 ans ça veut dire
deux choses la première chose c'est que
pour les Ukrainiens les Ukrainiens ils
sont appris à être résilient à vivre
avec la guerre à vivre avec les
sacrifices qu'il convient de faire pour
ces efforts là pendant ce neuf ans il y
a eu des attaques il y a eu des soldats
qui mourraient et il y a de sacrifices
de la part des l'ensemble de la société
ukrainienne bien entendu c'était à
l'échelle moindre mais n'empêche donc
pour les Ukrainiens il n'est pas
question de se fatiguer cela fait 9 ans
bientôt 10 que ça dure mais en même
temps cela aussi montre bien qu'il n'y a
vraiment pas tant à craindre de la du
changement de l'opinion on va dire
occidental ni de soutien parce que tout
comme la guerre elle jure depuis 9 ans
le soutien on va dire des États-Unis
dure un changement de majorité aux
États-Unis
il y a eu des changements de majorité
aux États-Unis il y a eu des changements
ou de président aux États-Unis les
radars médiatiques étaient moins étaient
moins centrés peut-être à tort mais sur
sur l'Ukraine et sur ce qui se passait
dans les régions occupées vous voyez ce
que je veux dire maintenant un dernier
mot là-dessus ensuite
c'est assez
diffamé
laine c'est aussi difficile assez
difficile de l'arrêter parce qu'il faut
il faut comprendre que ce ne sont pas
des décisions qui sont prises comme ça à
va vite c'est son
thématiques planifiées qui rentrent dans
les budgets dans la dans les lignes de
la diplomatique mais enfin ce n'est pas
quelque chose qui va changer du jour au
lendemain je vais vous donner la parole
dans un instant à tous les deux
là-dessus mais d'abord on va donc se
concentrer sur cette information l'une
des informations les plus importantes de
ces dernières 24 heures la décision
américaine de livrer des munitions
contenant de l’uranium appauvri je
propose à Quentin calmer de me rejoindre
sur ce plateau pour la première
chronique de ce sens public bonsoir
Quentin sur ce sur ce plateau ravi de
découvrir et oui il est beau notre
nouveau voilà c'est évidemment
anecdotique dans le contexte mais voilà
on est très heureux de pouvoir
bénéficier de cet outil qui est qui est
vraiment performant alors parlons de
cette aide américaine avec une annonce
un milliard de dollars supplémentaires
justement on va des images effectivement
puisque Anthony blinken et détail keV
hier c'était la quatrième visite même du
secrétaire d'État américain depuis le
début de l'invasion russe il a rencontré
volo divers elenski vous le voyez sur
ces images l'occasion pour lui de
réaffirmer le soutien américain à
l'Ukraine afin de garantir je cite que
nous maximisions les efforts et que nous
déployons pour relever le défi immédiat
de la contre-offensive à expliquer donc
le chef de la diplomatie c'était hier
écoutez Anthony blinken
les progrès de la contre-offensive en
cours se sont accélérés ces dernières
semaines cette nouvelle aide contribuera
à la maintenir et à lui donner un nouvel
élan
les Américains qui vont livrer davantage
de munitions pour l'artillerie et les
systèmes imams Javelin et les systèmes
anti-chats des munitions pour les chats
Abrahams à evront bientôt en Ukraine
précisé la porte-parole de la Maison
Blanche ainsi que des systèmes de
défense entière et justement ce sont ces
armes destinées au charavams qui font
polémique voilà ce sont des munitions
vous le disiez Thomas
uranium appauvri l'uranium est un métal
lourd radioactif capable de perforer les
blindages ces munitions sont
controversées en raison des risques
toxiques pour les militaires et la
population c'est d'ailleurs davantage le
risque de toxicité chimique que de
radioactivité qui inquiète et depuis
cette annonce c'est l'ambassade de
Russie à Washington a condamné cette
décision de livraison dame qui selon
elle est un signe clair de des
États-Unis je cite et ce midi le Kremlin
a réagi selon les Russes l'utilisation
de ces armes par le passé à entraîner
une hausse effrénée je cite de cancer et
donc une très mauvaise nouvelle dont la
responsabilité incombra aux États-Unis
c'est ce qui a déclaré le porte-parole
du kremain d'une Dimitri parceque merci
beaucoup Quentin pour pour tout toutes
ces précisions général Goma on va
commencer par faire de la pédagogie
c'est quoi ces obus sésame ces munitions
à uranium enrichit de quoi on parle en
fait un obus dans un partenaire est fait
pour percer un blindage adverse voir une
casemate ou un bunker adverse et pour ça
effectivement on a soit des flèches donc
l'obus à la fin il termine par une
flèche qui est faite soit en tungstène
soit effectivement en uranium appauvri
l'uranium appauvri permet effectivement
de percer encore plus facilement le
blindage d'un chat adverse ça a été très
utilisé pendant la première guerre du
Golfe ça a été utilisé pendant la guerre
au Koso et ça a été également utilisé
pendant les premières phases de la
Seconde Guerre du fout la guerre en Irak
mené par les Américains est-ce que la
France possède des munitions de ce type
alors on en possédait et on en possède
plus aujourd'hui de fait c'est ce que
disait votre journaliste la toxicité
chimique existe on se souvient du
syndrome du Golfe qu'on appelait
syndrome du Golfe on appelait ça
également syndrome au Kosovo est-ce que
c'était lié à ses armes à l'uranium
appauvri rien ne la prouvé jusqu'à
présent
en réalité ça ce que disent les Russes
et totalement faux il y a pas eu plus de
cancer après
l'ambassadeur oui parce qu'en fait le
mot uranium tout de suite on pense à
l'uranium au sens nucléaire alors que
c'est pas ça du tout là il s'agit de
d'un métal qui va aider à percer un
blindage on va détailler peut-être un
peu ces séries si oui est-ce qu'il y a
pas une forme d'hypocrisie de la Russie
puisqu'elle même dispose de ses
munitions est-ce qu'elle les a déjà
employés sur ce terrain on est en plein
dedans c'est à dire que effectivement
les deux adversaires s'accusent de tous
les mots et c'est on est à la guerre et
je rappelle que les l'une des victimes à
la guerre c'est la c'est à dire c'est la
vérité
et là on a on est en plein dedans et ça
rend notre travail collectif plus
compliqué j'ai oncle en termes
stratégique ces armes il pourrait servir
à quoi sur le terrain il faut bien voir
que l'objectif le temps compte
l'objectif c'est que cette contrevancie
délivre des résultats d'ici 2 mois en
fait parce que vous lui dites voilà le
risque météo précisément pour arriver
aussi fort que possible dans pourquoi
pas un jour mais pour parler voilà sous
la pression des Américains et des
élections dont on parlait voilà dans la
mesure où le verrou de la supérioritaire
aérienne est inaccessible et c'est le
seul verrou qui permettrait c'est le la
condition préalable à tout succès au sol
se verrou là il reste au cadenacé certes
il y aura peut-être des F16 mais dans
une temporalité qui est de 1 2 3 et plus
en plus et donc par conséquent ce sera
peut-être une garantie de sécurité pour
une adhésion future à l'OTAN ou autre
mais ça ne va pas changer la temporalité
ça ne va pas être un Game changer dans
cette contre-offensive il reste donc il
reste que disait de général Goma
c'est-à-dire de tenter de couper le pont
terrestre qui a effectivement sur ce
front sud-est et là les ukrainiens et
c'est le point positif de la
contre-offensive ont une avancée sur la
première ligne de défense qu'il commence
à questionner il y en aura encore une
autre deuxième mais si toutefois il
passe la première et là pour passer ces
lignes de défense il est plus question
de supérioritaire aérienne là c'est du
combat véritablement terrestre avec
l'efficacité de ce que peuvent révéler
les armes terrestres c'est-à-dire les
blindés les chats et l'infanterie
infinie et donc il y a vraiment un
besoin prégnant d'être beaucoup plus
efficace dans la percée de ces lignes
oui donc ce que j'entends c'est que
je fais le B aussi mais
cette annonce elle correspond à une
demande qui vient du terrain quoi qui
vient
peut-être généralement
par les Britanniques avec leur charger
ils ont déjà donné des obus à l'uranium
appauvrit donc effectivement c'était
déjà posé la question il y a quelques
cela ça n'a pas créé plus de problèmes
que ça ça rend le char plus efficace
qu'il n'est et donc là ça crée des
problèmes parce que les Russes
réagissent et on tombe dans le piège en
quelque sorte parce que parce que les
Américains l'annoncent et dire c'est
bien qu'il annonce qu'il va se prendre
une certaine transparence sur le les
conséquences on va dire chimiques de
cette guerre la pollution des des sols
si on essaye de se projeter dans un
après-guerre Mariana perab beniciou que
c'est c'est vertigineux peut-être ce qui
attend un peu il faut se rappeler que
même avant la grande invasion depuis
2014 du fait de l'occupation russe du
Dombas à l'Ukraine était déjà l'un
depuis les plus miner au monde
maintenant c'est le pays le plus mignon
au monde ça c'est la première chose mais
il y a il n'y a pas que ça il y a la
pollution pyrotechnique il y a tous les
obus toutes les munitions qui ne se sont
pas et qui ne sont pas explosés et qui
peuvent constituer un danger pour les
populations civ dans l'avenir mais là
pareil il n'y a pas que ça il y a
également tout tous les métaux lourds
toutes les substances chimiques qui
peuvent trouver dans toutes les autres
munitions finalement qui qui
sont maintenant renfermés dans les sols
ukrainiens et qui rendent ces sols en
pratique alors que le crâne possède un
ton important de solfertile au monde en
fait et que le monde entier a besoin de
se l'Ukrainien pour se nourrir il faut
se rappeler qu'il y a il y a ceux de
filles là également le défi des
pollutions de nappe phréatique mais
également de tous les accidents qui ont
pu provoquer des pollutions du fait de
combat ou de des actes des sabotages ou
même du rupture de barrage de Novak
Haruka donc en fait pour l'instant il
est très difficile de chiffrer ça nous
pouvons savoir que le chantier sera
gigantesque on s'y prépare déjà et déjà
de
la reconstruction c'est à dire qu'on en
a déjà parlé il y a des programmes le
moral même c'est important dans des
villes qui ont été bombardées qu'on
reconstruit
les programmes pour le déminage parce
que c'est quelque chose qui est plus
facile ensuite il y a également de
programmes qui se créent pour faire une
sorte de réflexion quand même pour une
sorte dépollution globale parce qu'il y
a encore une fois il s'agira de sol il
s'agira de ville il s'agira de nappes
phréatiques et ça c'est très important
et pourquoi on dit ça quand même c'est
parce qu'à chaque fois qu'un sujet
polémique arrive comme ça avec une
petite stimulation du côté de la
propagande de russe il faut quand même
se rappeler que c'est la guerre
elle-même c'est l'agression russe qui
génère cette pollution et qu'elle ne se
limite pas à un tel ou tel type un tel
ou tel type de munition et que plus la
guerre du rat plus il y aura des combats
plus il y aura de pollution donc une
ciné si on fait le compte si on veut que
l'environnement soit préservé au maximum
il faut
donner la guerre la plus rapidement
possible mais je crois que c'est pas les
quelques obus on va parler en centaines
de buts à l’uranium qui changeront la
donne enfin la pollution du sol
craignant et malheureusement déjà depuis
longtemps et ça te fait s'empirer tous
les jours alors les solutions pour
terminer la guerre le plus rapidement
possible la question de la diplomatie se
pose également Tam traduis je me tourne
vers vous puisqu'il y a il y a eu une
sortie on va dire critiquer voire très
critiqué de l'ancien président de la
République française Nicolas Sarkozy et
oui c'était la grande polémique de l'été
au cœur de l'été en plein mois d'août
une sortie médiatique et donc polémique
Nicolas Sarkozy donne une interview
fleuve au Figaro Magazine à l'occasion
de la parution de la suite de ces
mémoires et il donne son analyse de la
guerre en Ukraine voici ces mots qui qui
choquent il faut avancer trouver une
voie de sortie la Russie et voisine de
l'Europe et le restera la diplomatie la
discussion l'échange reste les seul
vient de trouver une solution acceptable
sans compromis rien ne sera possible et
nous courrons le risque que les choses
dégénèrent à tout moment Nicolas Sarkozy
critique aussi la position actuelle de
la France un de ses anciens conseillers
juge d'ailleurs ces propos dans la
foulée honteux tout simplement il y a
une prise de distance d'Emmanuel Macron
il y a également François Hollande qui
pointe je le cite les erreurs de Nicolas
Sarkozy la machine s'emballe jusqu'à
réveiller et bien un ancien Premier
ministre Lionel Jospin qui sort de sa
retraite politique on a eu l'impression
de quelques bons en arrière de quelques
années l'ancien Premier ministre prend
la plume dans le Figaro voilà ce qu'il
dit il dit il est grave en effet de voir
un ancien président de la République
française a rebours de la position
officielle de son pays adopté la thèse
et servir les intérêts du pays agresseur
d'un peuple dont nous déclarons l'ami
avant de fustiger la sollicitude de
Nicolas Sarkozy à l'égard de la Russie
Nicolas Sarkozy a-t-il répliqué et
comment pas forcément en pleine
promotion de son livre on l'entend
beaucoup Nicolas Sarkozy c'est un invité
de choix pour les radios pour les
plateaux télé voilà sa réponse à Lionel
Jospin hier sur France 5 et gentil
monsieur Jospin de sortir de sa retraite
donner des leçons s'ils connaissait
quelque chose ça serait en l'occurrence
je pose la question est-ce que l'entrée
de l'Ukraine dans l'OTAN favorise la
paix ou pas c'est une question noble
c'est pas une question ma réponse est
non mais c'est pas une surprise
puisqu'en 2008 avec Angela Merkel on s'y
est opposé pourquoi on s'y est opposé
parce que quand vous agitez la muleta
sous le museau du taureau faut pas
s'étonner qu'il fonce voilà Nicolas
Sarkozy dans le style Nicolas Sarkozy
alors je ne sais pas si Alain Juppé lui
il connaît quelque chose mais voilà que
dans le point interrogé lui aussi à
propos de ses propres mémoires
intitulées une histoire française un
autre ancien Premier ministre donc elle
a Juppé se voit forcer d'aborder
l'actualité internationale et les propos
de son ex rival à la primaire de la
droite et voilà ce qu'il répond il
répond d'abord je ne vais pas porter de
jugement sur ce que dit Nicolas Sarkozy
ni m'exprimer sur ce qu'il faut faire
avec l'Ukraine mais évidemment forcément
un oui mais il y a forcément un maire
mais voilà je conteste fermement la
thèse de ceux qui disent que nous avons
encerclé isolé Poutine en menaçant de
faire entrer l'Ukraine dans l'OTAN ce
qui expliquerait sa réaction la
polémique est-elle éteinte on le voit
non des vidances en retrait de la vie
politique mais pas retraité un Nicolas
Sarkozy a vu son interview prendre une
résonance mondiale ce qu'on a parlé et
bien des réactions françaises mais il y
a aussi eu des réactions en Ukraine il y
a eu des réactions en Russie les uns
dénonçants une logique criminelle les
autres c'est-à-dire Vladimir Poutine en
l'occurrence se disant largement
d'accord avec l'ancien chef de l'État
tout cela ne va pas s'éteindre d'autant
plus que et bien cette polémique elle
sert bien sûr et bien la bête médiatique
que Nicolas Sarkozy qui aurait vendu
sans targue sa maison d'édition 24 000
exemplaires de son livre en une semaine
qu'on parle de moi en bien ou en mal peu
importe l'important c'est qu'on parle de
moi merci Tom pour cette analyse pour
plutôt je vais reprendre les mots de
l'ancien président de la République la
diplomatie la discussion l'échange reste
les seuls moyens de trouver une solution
acceptable je voudrais vous entendre les
uns et les autres là-dessus général
Gomar pour commencer est-ce que ça vous
choque d'entendre ça dans la bouche d'un
ancien président français alors ce que
dit un des je crois que c'est j'ose pas
effectivement j'ose pas qui dit
effectivement que il devrait faire
attention à ce que dit la France puisque
effectivement dans la République il y a
un président en exercice qui s'exprime
maintenant quand on regarde ce qui se
passe réellement sur le terrain en fait
on assiste à un véritable bras de fer
entre deux adversaires comme dans tout
le droit de faire on sait pas exactement
ce dont l'autre est capable ou ce qui
lui reste en réserve
et aujourd'hui on en est là et c'est
vrai que dans une guerre la diplomatie
est nécessaire et impérative aujourd'hui
chacun espère gagner la guerre en
battant l'autre parce que est-ce que
jusqu'à ce que l'autre c'est une guerre
d'attrition jusqu'à ce que l'autre c'est
lève les pouces donc on le plus possible
c'est exactement ça on veut affaiblir
l'autre jusqu'à ce qu'il comme au bras
de fer qui s'effondre battu par par
l'autre bras de fer
c'est là où on en est c'est-à-dire que
si effectivement il y a pas et je pense
qu'il y a des dialogues en parlant en
dessous forcément et les services
secrets servent en partie à ça voir par
des voix parallèles etc mais aujourd'hui
comment est-ce qu'on termine cette
guerre quel est le gaine changer qui
fait changer ses bières en 1917
rappelons-nous le premier guerre
mondiale Géral Pétain qui prend le
commandement des armées françaises en
fait attend deux choses fait une
véritable pause opérationnelle après les
offensives de Nivelles contre la ligne
induboard nous en véritable défaite il
arrête la guerre enfin une espèce de
pose et il attend quoi en fait l'arrivée
des chars et l'arrivée des Américains
qui seront le véritable gamechanger même
si l'armée américaine n'est pas du tout
l'armée américaine d'aujourd'hui et
c'était des soldats pas du tout aguerris
donc voilà en fait ce qui peut permettre
à l'Ukraine de gagner la guerre au-delà
de la DIP classique est toujours
nécessaire c'est ce gamechanger comment
est-ce qu'on atteint ce gamechader pour
l'instant on n'est pas la réponse pour
l'instant on le voit pas vraiment c'est
ce que c'est ce que vous nous dites même
question est-ce que c'est propos vous
choque là je rebondis sur la question du
Game chanter on l'a dit le Game changers
ce serait effectivement d'avoir une
dimension aérienne qui soit
véritablement exploitée de sorte à ayant
le préalable de la supériorité aérienne
qui aujourd'hui en fait est à l'avantage
de la Russie et c'est plus prévenant
encore depuis août et bien qui
permettrait d'avoir des résultats au sol
et ses talents sur peut-être un an de
combat c'est pas le cas et tout à
l'heure ce sera pas le cas avant et ce
sera pas le cas donc sur Game changer il
n'est pas là donc en termes de
d'approche réaliste des relations
internationales s'il y a pas
militairement une capacité à inverser le
rapport de force de façon drastique de
fait la diplomatie qui a vocation à
accompagner avant à prévenir la guerre
et maintenir la paix pendant et à
trouver la paix après ne peut qu'être à
l'oeuvre elle ne peut pas être de côté
et donc là maintenant je je m'exprime
d'avant chef de l'État français
une autre que ce soit le chef de
l'étalon la diplôme assis et je tiens
cette enseignement d'un ambassadeur
auprès de qui j'ai eu la grande chance
de travailler qui me disait mais vous
savez Jérôme quand quelqu'un avait faire
le sale boulot il me faut surtout pas
l'en empêcher bon vous disiez à juste
titre que les Américains que on
alimentait pas la guerre mais la
résistance les Américains ont dit il
faut permettre à la à l'Ukraine de
résister mais pas forcément l'amener
jusqu'à la victoire tout simplement
parce que au-delà des considérations
morales c'est peut-être pas pensable
sans engager dans une escalade ou les
Alliés seraient eux-mêmes engagés donc
résister mais pas gagné voilà donc un
moment éLECTION AMÉRICAINE faisant et
c'est quand même le protagoniste de
cette affaire avec la Russie et
peut-être la Chine d'ailleurs qui reste
d'ailleurs silencieuse là à un moment
des pourparler vont se profiler parce
que techniquement on ne pourra pas votre
expression je vais vous donner la parole
juste après à Mariana qui qui fait le
sale boulot alors
qui a parlé donc c'est Nicolas qui a un
retentissement international et
finalement peut-être que si on se donne
rendez-vous dans un an ou dans deux ans
et qu'on regarde tels que les choses se
seront passées on sera peut-être pas
loin d'une équation il y aura eu des
pour parler avec un équilibre qui se
sera fait sur le terrain avec peut-être
et ses regrettable mais peut-être un
certain nombre de concessions
territoriales d'un côté et peut-être un
certain nombre de consolidation de gains
de l'autre Nicolas Sarkozy la question
la temporalité n'est pas bonne à dire et
celui qui dit la vérité en premier sera
exécuté mais de fait si on regarde et là
je parle en tant que prospectiviste mais
si on regarde voilà comment peut-on
prolonger les courbes au vu du rapport
de force sur le terrain et des
équilibres géopolitiques on a parlé
encore une fois des États-Unis de la
Chine mais aussi de ce Sud global qui
quelque part joue sur le ressentiment
aussi antioxydantal et qui nous laisse
pas les coûts pour faire ce que l'on
fait aussi et bien précisément il est
possible qu'on arrive à une équation qui
soit proche de celle qui est des
peintres Mariana finalement quand vous
entendez des voilà des analyses comme
comme c'est là oui mais c'est c'est
intéressant est-ce que il y a j'imagine
que oui des voix diplomatiques des
pressions internationales qui essaient
de pousser cet argument auprès de du
président zellenski il faut se préparer
à négocier cette guerre ne va pas
pouvoir durer éternellement il va
falloir peut-être accepter de s'arrêter
là enfin vous voyez ce que je veux dire
alors j'aimerais bien qu'on parce qu'on
a quand même chafaudé beaucoup de
suppositions d'hypothèses donc
j'aimerais bien qu'on rentre plus vers
l'analyse alors déjà pour qu'il y ait de
pour parler et même on va dire leur
éventuel possibilité théorique il faut
bien que les parties veuillent bien
négocier et le les autorités
ukrainiennes
ont dit depuis un an et demi qu'il
s'était à volontaire pour discuter enfin
discuter de choses je le retrait de
l'armée russe par exemple
et en même temps les autorités Kremlin
n'a jamais montré aucun le moindre signe
de volonté de négocier quoi que ce soit
donc en fait là pour l'instant là c'est
conversations ça reste tout simplement
stérile un lampe sens de tout signe de
volonté de négocier du côté russe ça
c'est la première chose non mais c'est
vrai la question non non mais ça c'est
ça c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose
c'est normal d'une certaine façon que
les alliés de l'Ukraine se posent cette
pose cette question non non le montant
de l'aide qui était depuis on peut ces
questions même aux responsables
ukrainien régulièrement les les
journalistes occidentaux posent ces
questions et aux responsables ukrainien
il vient de réponse oui bien sûr si on
peut bien sûr un jour négocier quelque
chose maintenant est-ce qu'on peut
négocier je ne sais pas comment les
concessions territori territoriales non
mais c'est absolument possible alors
premièrement sédit par l'Ukraine et
c'est dit très enfin très très
clairement par les alliés de l'Ukraine
et c'est aussi dit qu'à même par le
droit international donc quand même il
faut se rassurer qu'il n'y aura pas des
négociations des négociations de ce
tordre là tout simplement parce que dans
le droit international ce n'est pas
quelque chose qui est possible et ce
n'est pas quelque chose qui est
admissible ni pour le crème ni pour les
Alliés
amour rapide c'est vraiment la fin du
débat général Goma il faudrait quoi une
avancée quand même ukrainienne quelque
chose de suffisamment marquant pour que
éventuellement cette porte de la
négociation de la diplomatie s'en trouve
je ne sais pas mais quand on voit en
fait l'avancée est très très limitée
c'est à dire que si on rejoint la mère
d'Azov il reste plus de 100 km ils ont
avancé de 5 km ça va prendre ça va
prendre des jours et des jours si on
perd un bataillon pour conclure 10km2
ils ont 400 bataillons environ les
Ukrainiens ça fait quand même beaucoup
de bataillon perdus donc en fait on voit
bien qu'on arrive aux limites un peu de
de cette guerre et c'est là où ça
devient compliqué c'est-à-dire et pour
des responsables politiques pour des
litières politiques c'est extrêmement
compliqué parce que le nombre de pertes
humaines et je dirais
exponentielle
c'est très très important bien sûr les
chiffres ne sont pas connus mais enfin
on peut imaginer qu'il y a beaucoup de
morts malheureusement merci beaucoup
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat qui était passionnant géant que je
vais appeler le titre de votre livre la
prospective stratégique une nouvelle
approche pour améliorer la prise de
décision publiée aux éditions
brochées à bientôt sur Hermann édition
airban les gros yeux bah oui évidemment
il faut il faut il faut dire merci à son
éditeur donc ce sont les éditions merci
à tous encore une fois à bientôt sur sur
ce plateau